chris waters here with a gamespot news  update if you played pt the demo for the  upcoming silent hills game then you may  remember this woman lisa who is not at  all weird or frightening in any way i  mean she didn't seem particularly  friendly in pt but in metal gear solid 5  it looks like she'll be on your side or  at least an inflatable doll likeness of  her after only recently unveiling the  use of a big boss decoy kojima unveiled  a lisa version of the decoy with the  same knock him off the cliff ability big  boss also used the decoy on his little  wolf puppy buddy who managed to keep his  cool much much better than gamespot's  own mary kish 2048  there was a lot of metal gear solid news  coming out of the tokyo game show last  week and we've got it all up on  gamespot.com for you to enjoy